Las Vegas Aces have won it all they
defeated the Connecticut sun in game
four of the finals today making history
as the first Las Vegas Pro Team to bring
home a championship Madison Kimbrough
joins us live from the Westgate
Sportsbook tonight as people are
continuing to celebrate this Madison
yeah a big reaction here as you can see
behind me a lot of people
the aces came through with a major win
today big Championship defeating the
Connecticut Sun by seven points Las
Vegas quickly becoming a Sports Hub and
those here at Westgate thrilled at this
historic win take a listen
I wish they would have won it here
because we'd have been celebrating
tonight with them but yeah it was a
remarkable accomplishment
um I love watching the women's
basketball league Asia Wilson's a beast
and you know she did a thing today
this Championship is the first for a
major professional sports franchise in
Las Vegas so all eyes on the WNBA
tonight the celebration will continue on
Tuesday down on the Strip there will be
a Rally route beginning at Caesar's
Palace and ending at a stage in front of
the Bellagio Fountains the rally is free
and open to the public that starts at 5
30 on Tuesday again that's coming up
this week on Tuesday starts at 5 30 free
to the public a lot of people
anticipating it's going to look a lot
like the NFL draft experience so a lot
of people really excited for this big
championship in this big turnout sending
it back to you Sasha
all right Madison thank you so much and
uh Las Vegas mayor Carolyn Goodman
tweeting about this big Las Vegas Aces
wind saying congratulations to our WNBA
Champions the Las Vegas Aces what a team
what a talent what a victory you have
made Las Vegas so proud